Everything in the universe is created from the sequencing of numbers.
There's no straight lines in nature.
Energy moves in a wave, then when it encounters a barricade, it spirals,
and then eventually, as it's far enough away from its energy source, it turns to chaos.
Hello, everybody. Welcome to another episode of Cutters,
clinic live. I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters. We have a special guest today, Deanna Ansum.
She is up in the Winnipeg, Canada, unfortunately.
Sorry, I'm just kidding.
Well, if it were January, I'd be fully in agreement with you.
That's it. I'm sure it's absolutely gorgeous up there. We are not very far from you in
Minnesota and Wisconsin here. We're going to talk about the fashion. I'm really, really
dying to hear what you have to say about the fashion because literally you talk to
chiropractors and physical therapists that rarely is it discussed. I mean, I practiced
cadetiality and applied cadetiality for a year. So we worked on the fashion layer constantly,
but hardly anybody else would talk about it in the other people that would understand what fashion
was was deer cutters. That's true because you're literally able to see it then, yes.
Let's get to know you a little bit better. Tell us a little bit about you.
So I certified as an athletic therapist up here in Canada back in 1995.
And at the time, I had a really strong practice. I always focused on deep tissue work,
and I had really strong hands. It was really good at finding the adhesions and the scar tissue
in bodies, but my own personal body was really not in a good place, even though I was applying what
I had learned to be healthy, eating less calories than expending with energy, doing what I believed to
be true as healthy exercise, but I was really struggling. My size and shape were awful. I was 50 pounds
overweight, struggling with anxiety, depression, chronic pain, constipation, and it seemed
that the harder that I worked to try to direct my body in and the path that I thought I would create
positive change, the worse I became. So compound that with a feeling of failure, I was really struggling.
And yet I'm working with a lead athlete. So it was this paradox where I'm doing what I'm trained
to do, and I've seen these lead athletes, yet what I'm doing for myself isn't working. So when I
turned 30, I made some big changes in my life. And as a result of those changes, I started having
serious anxiety attacks. However, this one anxiety attack in particular was the seed of everything to come
because in that moment, I awakened to so many ahas. And so the first thing that happened was I
actually thought I was going to die. I was literally frozen with my breath in this moment of panic.
In what of your anxiety attacks? In one of my anxiety attacks. And for some reason, unconsciously,
I dove my hand deep into my abdomen. And that was a really interesting moment for me because I
carried most of my extra weight in that space of my body. So I rarely, if ever, touched it. I certainly
didn't move my hand deeply into this space. The first thing though that I encountered was pain.
But the pain brought me out of my crazy thinking. I was like, okay, I'm grounded. I'm breathing. I'm
alive. I'm going to live another day. But what was fascinating was as I was intuitively exploring in
this tissue, I recognized that it felt marbled with scar tissue, even though I hadn't had any injury
or surgery specifically in that area. And suddenly, I'm realizing, well, no wonder when I'm coming home
from a five mile run dripping wet with sweat, that my belly would still feel cold. And I recognize there
was no blood flow getting to this tissue because of all of this scar tissue. Or now I understand more
specifically adhesion in this area. Now at the same time, I had also started the practice of yoga.
And it was lovely because the first class that I had, I had an amazing teacher. And about every 30
seconds, she would be prompting us to breathe. And every time she reminded us to breathe, I recognized
I wasn't really breathing. You know, I'm holding my breath or I'm breathing in a really shallow way. So
this became a really foundational component for my understanding of what's going on in the body.
So as I'm exploring in my abdomen with my hands, I'm first of all feeling really calm. And that
was just this beautiful moment because I was rarely calm. I spent about 30, 45 minutes that first
evening woke up the next morning, a little tender in my abdomen, but I went to work and I worked on
my patients all day. And I came back and I was excited because I still felt really calm all day. And
I just had the sense of energy in this area that I hadn't experienced before. So I came home that
second night. I spent another 30, 45 minutes working in that same manner. And when I stood up, I felt
taller. And I went and I looked at myself in the mirror and I literally began to cry because my belly
was flatter than it had looked in years. And I tend to do everything to the extreme. So when I was
attempting to change my size and shape, I was doing 400 sit-ups a day, tie, bow, running. I mean,
I was trying absolutely everything. And again, the harder I worked, the more compressed, the more
ballooned, the more congested and toxic I became. So to have something so quickly created change,
literally in two days was just amazing to me. So every day I would come home from work after working
on my clients with my hands. And I would dive into my own body. And within two weeks, my chronic
back pain was going away. My whole outlook on life was changing. I started flipping my patients
over onto their backs. And I started applying a similar method to what I was doing on my own body
with them. And I was having unbelievable results. And very quickly, I started attracting therapists
that wanted to learn what I was doing because I was tapping into something that was creating this
amazing change. So that was that was back 24 years ago. And that was the seed of everything that has
or come forward today as a result of that anxiety attack. So I mean, I think our listeners as well
as I am wondering exactly what you were doing, were you doing deep like tissue massage on your belly?
So when you're talking about is that what you were visiting? Yes, but I wasn't like as an
athletic therapist, I always focused on deep tissue or come my clients. And so I mean, we were
trained in the typical strokes and all of those things. It wasn't that though. And in the beginning,
I wouldn't have even been able to explain it because I wasn't doing that. I was in and I was
following this path, the path of least resistance. And so now I can explain it very well. But in a moment,
I'm just following what seemed to be something guiding my hand for lack of a better word. So what I've
learned today is that what I was doing unconsciously was following the Fibonacci sequence. So now that I've
learned so much about this, everything in the universe is created from the sequencing of numbers.
It's the architecture of everything in life. There's no straight lines in nature. Energy moves in a wave
then when it encounters a barricaded spirals and then eventually as it's far enough away from its
energy source, it turns to chaos. You can see that if you see smoke leaving a pipe right where the
heat source is, there's a wave of smoke then it starts to spiral, then it's chaotic. So it was about
two years into me doing this when one of my patients said you should be teaching this and I thought wow
okay, I'm just kind of going with the flow. So I don't even really understand how to put this into
words. But then I started doing some research. And I recognized after reading The Flower of Life by
Dr. novella Melchizedek that I was actually following the Fibonacci sequence. So when I'm working on
the surface of the body, that's where the patterns are chaotic because we're more cold on the surface.
But under the chaos is the spiral, under the spiral is the wave and we want to have the wave
happen through the body because that indicates that there's space. So when it comes to fascia,
the goal is that it supports cell alignment. We have trillions of cells in the body and every cell
should have space in and around each cell. So the fascia-like skin to the body is the skin to the
cell interconnecting every single cell in the body. It's the communication system plus it provides both
mobility and stability. And as long as there's space, then there's ease of absorption of nutrients
into the cell as well as ease of toxins and everything else byproducts of functioning all of these things
taken away from the cell. So as long as there's space, there's ease of flow. And as long as there's flow,
there's really no issues in the body. It's when we have a lack of space in the body that we end
up having congestion, inflammation. We become colder in those spaces and then gravity manipulates
our body and it plays havoc with how we age and go through time. Do you have to go to a practitioner
to get this done? Do you teach this to lay people to do it to others' selves? How does your program work
go? Both, actually. I do have a teacher program where I teach people to do this on others. But
most importantly, my goal was always to teach people to self-care. Because we teach people how to understand
the language of pain in the most beautiful way. Pain is the baby crying. Yet we've been so conditioned
to be afraid of pain, to mask pain. We subconsciously, posturally move away from pain and over time,
that really creates the havoc in the body because we are under this constant force of gravity.
Gravity is pulling us down toward the earth. Then we don't just compress linearly. We wind down one
direction or another. So what happens is the adhesions that form through the layers are created to
keep stability in the body. So if I'm right-handed and I'm always moving this way, I start shifting my
center of gravity over to the left. If I don't have something to support that, eventually I'm going to
tip off balance. So the collagen in the fascia, there's a combination of primarily collagen in the
last one. The collagen gets drawn to these compressed areas and builds up almost scaffolding to stop
that tipping. But collagen has no elasticity just like scar tissue. So it creates these big barricades
in the body. So that in turn causes tension in the equal and opposite side of the body, which is
typically the back of the body. So when we are teaching people how to self-care, it's really about
teaching how to use pain as your guide. And we have two different tools called the block body and the
block baby that we use as the props for the self-care purpose. The reason that they're made with this
shape and out of the material that we use is because fascia will grip and adhere to bone with a
forest up to 2,000 pounds per square inch. But it's a magnetic seal. So wood or bamboo are the
mediums that we use. They're similar in density to bone. And the goal is that we get to those adhesions
right at the root of the problem, which is deep to the bone. So if we use something that's more
porous like fascia roller that's maybe made out of plastic or a yoga block that's made out of plastic,
they're porous. And we need something dense like bone so that when we lie on these tools,
we have this equidistant compression creating heat through the layers of fascia because pressure
over time creates heat. And the goal is that we melt through the adhesions because literally what's
happening as the adhesions are developed, the tissue becomes colder in temperature. So they work
together that the temperature and the adhesions form as a result of this cooling down of the tissue
to create stability. So we lie on the tool to put the heat back into those spaces that have become
cold because pressure over time creates heat, creates blood flow. We combine that though with teaching
people proper diaphragmatic breathing. And I love getting into the topic of the diaphragm because
this is one of the three major pillars of fascia decompression. And without it, we don't get the results
that we need. So is it okay right now if I dive into the breath to explain this process a little
further? For sure. So I just want to bring my camera down for a moment. So the diaphragm is a
plate of muscle that supports the foundation of the ribcage. When we inhale, it moves down in the body
when we exhale, it lifts. If working properly, it's this muscle moving up and down, up and down,
it acts like a pump. It's the ceiling to the abdominal organs, the floor to the heart and the lungs
and everything above. So when it's strong, it helps support alignment as well as it keeps this whole
area of the body heated. The challenges, pain, fear and stress causes to reactively hold the breath
and this is a world full of pain, fear and stress. So pretty much everybody has shifted their breath
to some degree at least to be breathing through the muscles of the upper chest. Now this is problematic
because it is at the base of the lungs where the majority of the oxygen receptor sites reside.
So if we're breathing in this shallow upper chest kind of way, we're not pulling the air deeply
enough into the lungs to reach this bed of abundance of alveoli, they're called, where we have this
optimal absorption. And in fact, in Stephen Cope's book yoga and the quest for the true self,
he shared that we feed the body up to six times the oxygen when breathing diaphragmatically.
And every single cell in the body, first and foremost, requires oxygen to thrive. It's the fuel for
the ATP. So if we are lacking in oxygen, then our system doesn't have the energy to be able to
age in a healthy, functional way. And then we start to see aging and disease and pain and all
of the things that can accumulate as a result of a lack of breath. If you can even have the vision
of thinking of blowing up a balloon fully, when the balloon is fully blown up, it's round, it glows,
it almost defies gravity. Take half the air out of the balloon, it becomes dense, wrinkly,
it attracts dust and debris in the creases and it falls to the ground. So as we age, if we don't have
that strong breath, we start depleting the cells of the oxygen, they start to deflate, they absorb
and store toxins. And this is essentially what goes on in the body as we get older and we end up with
congested inflammation causing chaos inside the body. So when we learn to tap into proper
diaphragmatic breathing, it is a beautiful shift in the body. This is really where the magic happens
because this is how we heat the body. I always say that the diaphragm is like the body's furnace
breathing through the muscles of the upper chest is like having a space heater for your body. I live
in a 30 story building. So I mean, you know, when it gets cold, it's really cold. If my window breaks
in January and I don't have an ability to warm myself up, I'll probably die. If I only have one
space heater in my two room apartment, I'm only heating one room. But if I turn the buildings furnace
on, I heat the entire building. So understanding proper diaphragmatic breathing is really the key.
Now the challenge is there's a lot of people teaching breathing methods out there. But if we have not
been conscious of the breath, we fall in and we displace. So the belly extends. We displace the
organs. I might collapse this way. I'm compressing more the liver. I might compress this way more the
stomach, whatever direction I happen to collapse in. This is what's happening blocking this ability
for this heat to happen through here. So then again, I'm breathing through the muscles up here and
it's extremely limiting into the amount of oxygenation that we have. They also proved in 2014
through a study they did in Australia that 84% of weight loss comes through proper
exhalation. And I was so very excited when the study came out because back in my day and my 20s,
when I was working out and working really hard and getting bigger with my efforts, I understood
I wasn't breathing. So as much as I was working hard, I wasn't activating this beautiful energy body
through proper breathing to be able to move the toxins out. So they became stored. So basically,
as we compress, we balloon and we become more toxic. So through the combination of lying on the
tool, the block, for a minimum of three minutes as we teach people, combined with teaching people,
proper diaphragmatic breathing, we're heating on the outside as well as the inside of the body and
that becomes an extremely effective way at melting through the adhesion. So we create the space through
lying on the tool. We inflate the space through breathing and pumping it into that area that we're
focusing on. And then the third pillar is maintaining space, understanding proper postural foundation.
Because we're dominant on one side, we tend to shift over to the less dominant side to keep that
side free for action, but that creates a twisting in the body and a collapsing. So we teach people
how to support proper lower body foundation, which we call rooting, teaching the breath, the diaphragm.
That's the mid body, the core foundation, and then the third foundation that we really teaches the
tongue muscle. The tongue isn't just for talking and chewing, it's also in part designed to support
the weight of the head. If we don't strengthen that muscle appropriately, though, it also becomes a
hindrance. And as the rib cage gets pulled forward, the head gets pulled forward. Now we're strangling
the carotid arteries, the thyroid, the major lymphatic drainage sites. So as we start
aging in this forward rotational direction, we're basically strangling or blocking all these roadways
for flow, whether it's lymphatic flow, energy flow, blood and oxygen flow, all of it.
All this sounds wonderful, but to a lot of my listeners that may be dealing with cancer,
it sounds complicated. It's so simple. And that's what I love. Because we've really brought this down
to an incredibly simple practice. So we have a starter program. And essentially we've broken the
body into three parts. We always start in the core and ribs because the most important part is that we
activate the breath. We want to teach people how to learn how to breathe from the belly as opposed
from the upper ribs. And we're designed to breathe this way. God gave us this diaphragm to breathe
with, we just forgotten. So it doesn't take long to really pull that into the body and understand how to
do that. Then we focus on the lower body and then the upper body. And we've created programs to make
it very simple to do this work. And you do it lying down. You can do it on the floor. You can do it
in bed. We have videos that you follow. So there's really nothing that you have to think about. And
there's no skill required. You simply just follow along through the process. And we have a beautiful
support group of community where you can ask questions 24-7. And we have over 10,000 members that do
this work that are there to also provide support as well as two of my amazing block therapists that
man the group to be sure that they're always answering questions. But the process is very, very simple.
You're literally lying on the tool and you're following along with the videos that we've created.
So this, this is called block therapy that you develop and the only equipment needed are these
two little blocks, right? These two little blocks. Yep. And with the program, you get all the instruction.
So you get all of the classes and you have them lifelong. Well, that's great. So you just go online,
watch the videos, start with the basics. Then you have, you know, different levels. I'm sure
up there. Yes. Yes, we have a membership where we have a number of guided programs and people that
join the starter program also get a two week free trial in the membership. If they only do the work
in the starter program, you're still going to get phenomenal benefits. And what's really nice,
there's nine classes in that starter program. But each time you do the work, you're diving deeper into
the layers of the fascist. So even though the classes are the same in that starter program,
you're touching cells that are deeper each time you go in because as you melt, you lengthen. And then
you go deeper and you pull up the deeper, older issues in your body to deal with and move out of the
body through that process. I'm really excited about this one. I used to do a lot more hands-on work
when we saw people in the office. There was a all-time higher printer way back in the 40s and 50s and
60s. His name was Dr. Baker D. Jardin, a French Canadian, I believe, that developed a technique of deep
facial work on the abdominal cavity, and he called it bloodless surgery. Oh, I think you might
want to look up that book. I will. Probably not in print anymore, so it might be difficult to find.
But I read that that really changed my life at how we worked on people's organs that physically
worked on the facial layer of organs and breaking that up. And we saw phenomenal results with that.
And so what I'm excited about, your program is that you're teaching people how to do similar things
themselves at home. Tell me a little bit about some of the maybe testimonials you've had with people
with pain, because that is obviously an issue with a lot of people with serious disease and certainly
with cancer. What kind of results do you see with that? Oh, and thank you for asking that. It's so
exciting. And as soon as you said that one case just jumps to my mind, she's actually now in my
teacher program, a woman, her name is Lisa. We actually did a YouTube discussion so you can see her
and come out and share this. I think it was about a year and a half or two years ago. She on her sled,
she lives somewhere cold, but on her sled drove into a nice wall at like 80 miles an hour and she
they didn't think she was going to live. She shattered her femur, her wrist, her elbow, concussion,
broken ribs. I mean, she was just a mess and this was during COVID as well. So now she's in the hospital
and she had just started block therapy maybe six months prior to this injury. So she already understood
the process and really understood the breath and she really shared that when she's in this hospital,
now she used what she learned from the breathing to manage the pain and of all the things that she had,
she said the worst pain was the arm like just the the burning and they didn't think she would ever
get use of her hand again because literally it was like this. She now has 90% use of her hand from
this process, but it was it was just fascinating because I ended up getting on with her once a week
and I didn't ever touch her with my hand. We were doing this all through Zoom when she had the tools
and I was guiding her how to work through her injuries and her body and within four months. It was
it was amazing. They didn't think she would walk again. She walks without a limp. Again, she's got the
majority of the use of her hand back. So she really was able to put herself back together beautifully
and what's really important to understand because again, we've got members and like from all over the
world that reach out to us because of chronic pain, tons of low back pain, tons of migraines, post
concussion syndromes, all these kinds of things. And what is important to note is we have to address
both the cause sites and the pain sites. So if we have a frozen shoulder and we go and we work on the
shoulder, we're not going to have more than probably a temporary relief at best in the scenario
because this is the pain site. This is being driven though from how the fascia manipulates the
entire body and will most specifically adhere with the greatest force at the calves and the feet
because again, the diaphragm is the furnace. It's the engine. So as we move away from that heat
source, that's where we become most frozen and sealed in the body. So of course the calves and
feet are the furthest away. So if I went and I had years of treatment on an area without getting to
that cause site, every time I start walking, I'm going to get pulled back into that same posture
that is pulling me out of alignment and cementing me in this negative way. So I'm not getting that blood
and oxygen flow to properly feed and heal. So we have so many people all over the world that are
dealing with chronic pain and getting the results because we teach them how to look at the body as a
hole and how to address the limbs, say something like scoliosis. We deal a ton with people with scoliosis
and really it's a function of what's going on in the limbs because we have the legs that are pulling
the body in these different directions as well as the arms and the hands and then the spine ends up
becoming manipulated as a result of what the limbs are doing. So then when we address the body
properly with this process, we can release those anchors that are torquing you in all these directions
and pull you back into that correct alignment, acute injury. We deal a ton with pain with acute
injury and pressure overrides pain. So this is probably one of the fundamental things that's really
important to understand. When we put pressure into the body, those fibers are larger in diameter than
the pain fibers. So pressure is a beautiful way to deal with pain in the moment without taking
something to kill the pain like a medicine, but it's a wonderful way to do that. And as we're going
through this process, those pressure fibers kick in once you turn on that beautiful breath. So suddenly
people feel it's a good pain and you're also the one in control of the pain. So we're not doing
something to you. You're choosing to do this all on your own with the guidance and we share
your breath as your guide. As long as you're breathing in a relaxed way, you're feeding and healing
the area. If anything hurts so much that it takes that relaxed breath away, that's your body saying,
well, too much, let's find a less intense way to approach this. So if you're on the floor working on
the bed is a less intense way to approach that. Is there anybody that should not be doing
block therapy? No. And the thing is, no matter your age, the condition you're in, what's happening
in your body, as soon as you learn to turn on your breath, you start oxygenating and detoxifying.
And that's what we need to do. We need to clear out the old to create space for the new. And so
everybody that chooses to do this will have improvement to some degree depending again on what
they choose to do and what we're starting with. So there's really no contraindications. There's
certain things like if someone's pregnant, we don't want you working directly in the belly. So
those kinds of things, but there's no contraindications as far as individuals that shouldn't do it.
Some people may not choose to do it, but those that do and dive in, we've got people with everything
from connective tissue disorders to Parkinson's, people with cancer and just chronic pain. I mean,
pretty much anything and everything. How can people get a hold of you? How can people learn more about
this? My website is block therapy.com. And we have a gift. So people can start this right away.
Even using a rolled up towel is really effective. And we've created a nine day program using that
rolled up towel. So people can dive into decompressing their fascia. So the tools are made of wood for
the reasons we've already discussed, but that rolled up towel becomes really dense in and of itself.
So we put you through nine different classes so that you can really feel the results of what this
work is doing as you turn on that breath and you lie on the towel as we teach you in those classes.
So you can start right away and decompress your fascia and gain the benefits immediately.
Well, I'm going to be the first client of our patients. So I got to jump in and do this myself.
I see just huge benefits in this. And I think our patients will too. So thanks for being on. We're
going to tie all your information into this so people can get a hold of you. Any last words of wisdom
that you could share? Absolutely. Posture and breath really, in my view, those are the two most
important things that we can do today to create a change for where we're moving tomorrow. And the
fascia is this beautiful system that is basically absorbed everything that we've done or experienced
in our lives. So what we do all the time matters most. And often we don't think that posture is a big
deal if we're slouch forward. So just understanding some basics and they don't have to cost you any
money. Your body was designed to breathe diaphragmatically. And we have two sides of the body that we
want to start to use equally so that we have symmetry and balance in the body. And those changes
we make today, again, will change the direction of how you age tomorrow. So some basic simple things
really, in my view, is what needs to happen in order to create a healthier body and slow down that
aging process. We do have a counter-force to gravity and it is that full exhalation. So tapping into
that is a beautiful gift you can give yourself. Thank you so much to you. And I appreciate it. We're
going to have all your information available for every day. A lot of people are going to jump in and
starting to learn block therapy. Well, thank you so much, Dr. Connors, for having me. It's been an
absolute pleasure. All right, bye-bye, Dr. Connors.